DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there, I'm
Daniel Sieberg as we continue
our coverage here on I/O Live.
You know, the attendees at
Google I/O got a chance to
check out the new
Nexus 7 tablet.
So we're here in Androidville
and we rounded up some of them
to see what they think.
MALE SPEAKER 1: The specs were
amazing and for the price, I
mean, it was incredible.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This
is very, very fast.
So I like it.
MALE SPEAKER 3: It's a perfect
size and my hands aren't
really that big and it
really fits great.
And I've enjoyed using
it so far.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Battery life
is absolutely insane.
I've used it, all last night and
all this morning and all
of today and I'm only
at like 75%.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's really cute
and it is compact also.
Not too heavy, also.
So I can just put it in my
handbag and then take it
anywhere I want.
MALE SPEAKER 5: It feels kind
of like a phone from its
weight, but it's a tablet.
So it's really nice.
MALE SPEAKER 1: You know, for me
I'm definitely be carrying
it around in my backpack
as a student.
You know, just throw in there.
It doesn't add any weight.
MALE SPEAKER 3: You know, I
could see myself using this on
planes, on the train,
all the places I go.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I have a
four-year-old and so once I
was using it and done browsing,
checking my emails
and so on, then I
gave it to her.
She downloaded a coloring
app and then she started
playing with it.
So we use it for all
kinds of things.
MALE SPEAKER 2: I'm going
to use it for my school.
I mean, I read a lot of books
and I read a lot.
I'm also studying computer
engineering, so maybe I'm
going to write some application
for this.
MALE SPEAKER 3: You know using
these in meetings, taking them
to conference rooms
is something that
I'm going to leverage.
MALE SPEAKER 4: I've been
playing games on it, I've been
reading books, I've been
listening to music.
And it was all just there.
MALE SPEAKER 1: You can use
it all day, you know watch
videos, play games,
read, whatever.
And then not worry about
charging it.
MALE SPEAKER 5: I like that you
have the full Google play
experience now in your hand
on such a good device.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Super
cool stuff.
I think I'm going to take this
one and check it out myself.
Stay tuned for more here
on Google I/O Live.